[Musik]
[Applaus]
55m die hindernisse das erste ist oben
drüber
das zweite das floß ist zum unten
durchdachten der tisch ist um darüber
springen und es letztlich wieder unten
durchbrochen
das ganze erfordert hat die
schnelligkeit und natürlich wassergefühl
und gleiten und sprung 8
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihm sagen der lauf war nicht ideal für
mich die abstände zu den hindernissen
haben nicht ideal passt spielen
teilweise viel zu knappen kommen dadurch
wenig weg zum ziel und letztendlich hat
er sagt doch einiges los
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er hätte also vormittag war supergeil
ich bin jetzt mal zweitbeste zeit immer
kurz reden und dann macht man weiter
[Musik]